اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي نهايه العمليه
العسكريه في مخيم جنين اكدت فصائل
فلسطينيه فشلت تصعيد حكومه نتنياهو
العسكري في تحقيق اي من اهدافه كيف بدات
حسابات الربح والخساره لدى الاسرائيليين
والفلسطينيين وما تاثير المباشر لهذا
التصعيد الميداني والسياسي على حسابات
وتوازنات وخطط طرفي المواجهه في ابعادها
المختلفه واي مستقبل ينتظر مربعات الصراع
بين الاسرائيليين والفلسطينيين في المرحله
القادمه
[موسيقى]
ولكن هذه مجرد بدايه ستكون هناك عمليات
عسكريه كبيره من هذا النوع مره بعد اخرى
وما خسرناه جندي واحد وعلى الارجح بسبب
النيران صديقه قواتنا كل اذا وضعنا قائمه
تتحدث عن ماذا ما هي الاهداف التي وضعتها
اسرائيل مقابل ماذا تحقق من هذه الاهداف
نرى بانه يعني استعاده الهيبه لم نرى بانه
فعلا اسرائيل قامت باعمال يمكن ان تكون
استعاده هيبه استعاده السيطره الامنيه
راينا بان هناك عمليات تفجير والغام اثناء
الانسحاب راينا ايضا عمليه في تل ابيب
راينا صواريخ من غزه
وبكل ما يتعلق بمعاقبه الحاضنه الجماهيريه
في التي احتضنت الحاضنه الشعبيه التي
احتضرت المقاومه من خلال التجريف قطع
المياه والكهرباء لا يمكن تسميتها ان هو
يعترف الان انه انه كسر الفلسطينيين
ودفعهم لتوقف عن بين قوسين الكفاح المسلح
هي مساله مستحيله وهذا بحد ذاته
يضاف الى ميزان الخساره الاسرائيليه
والربح الفلسطيني واسرائيل تعرف ان
دفع ثمن كبير للعيش حياه الرغيده
لمنع الفلسطينيه من التدمير حياتنا
المشكله كما قلنا دون يعني نتنياهو كان
هناك لديه اهداف داخليه لم تعلن ولكنها
كانت يعني على الطاوله والجميع تحدث عنها
نتنياهو عمليا يشهد
انهيارًا من ناحيه قوته السياسيه مقارنه
بالاحزاب الاخرى ولاحظنا بانه حتى خلال
العدوان على جنين خرجت الاحتجاجات يعني
ايضا نتنياهو اراد ان يهدئ
الاحتجاجات الداخليه التي كانت تخرج بسبب
التعديلات القضائيه خرجت هذه المظاهرات
خلال العدوان على الجنين واستمرت وهذا
الامر يظهر بانه ايضا الاهداف الداخليه لم
يستطع نتنياهو ان ينفذها
[موسيقى]
عن انجاز فلسطيني في في الجوله الاخيره
انه اسرائيل ارادت ان تعيد
فكفكه الحال الفلسطينيه السياسيه والوطنيه
والجغرافيه والاستخراج في جنين واعاده ما
يسمى قوه الردع عبر تحقيق الحد الاقصى من
الانجازات الى العدوان الاخير على جنين
هذا الموضوع
والذي اعادوا هو الخطاب الصهيوني
الاستعماري الذي بنى السلوك على فرضيه انه
اسرائيل قادم بين قوسين للقضاء على هذا
الارهاب بتمكين السلطه الفلسطينيه مستقبلا
من العوده للحكم في في جنين وكان الازمه
هي فقط في بين قوسين في المقاومه وفي ضعف
السلطه وليس في الاحتلال الذي يشكل سبب كل
هذه الازمات ما نشاهد اليوم على الارض في
جنين يظهر بانه
العمليه اضعفت مجانه السلطه وخاصه غياب
الاجهزه الامنيه عن حمايه المواطنين الامر
الذي يعني وضع السلطه في موقف محرج مع
جمهورها في ظل انه لاول مره تتبنى القياده
الفلسطينيه قياده الشرطه قياده منظمه
التحرير جمله جديده
انه اعلنت انه اوطالبت السلطه واجزه الامن
بالدفاع عن الشعب الفلسطيني وهذا خطاب
جديد حتى وان لم يتم ممارسه وتنفيذه تهنئه
الرهان على ابقاء السلطه خارج الصراع هو
امر يعني غير مضمون على الاقل في المنظور
الزمني القريب كنتيجه طبيعيه لما حصل في
جنين
الفلسطينيون لديهم رموز مثل هذه منذ مئات
السنوات وهذا ما ادى الى النكبه وعلى
الارجح سيواصلنا
تضامنهم ويتواصلون استخدام النظام المسلح
ولم يكن هناك حل مشكلته
الحياه في اسرائيل افضل وافضل يوما بعد
اخر وكل عقل وحياه الفلسطينيين ليست جيده
وهم يعانون واذا اردتم ان يضروا بذلك لعقد
اخر او لقرن اخر فليحصل نتنياهو اراد ان
يظهر وكانه هو من يقرر لم يدعوا مندوبي
الصهيونيه الدينيه الى اللقاءات التنسيق
الامني خلال
العدوان
وكان يعني يريد ان يرسل رساله بانه هو من
يسيطر وهو من يقود العمل الامني ايضا في
الدوله ولكن على ارض الواقع التيارات
الفاشيه هي من فرضت هذا التصعيد هذا
الالتحام
البطوله ما بين هاي المجموعات كتائب
القسام مع كتائب الاقصى مع مع سرايا القدس
مع كل الفلسطيني في ظل هذه الحاضن الجماه
ري الواسعه اعاد اعطاء شرعيه للمقاومه
المسلحه
يعني وهذه الحكومه وايضا
قطاع واسع من المجتمع الاسرائيلي الان يضع
جذور
نظام الفصل العنصري من البحر الى النهر